well Israel's close Ally the US says
it's sending additional military aid and
deploying an aircraft carrier group in
assure of support for Israel let's go
live to John hendin in Washington DC
Johnson the US deploying this aircraft
carrier strike group to the region
presumably all part of the unwavering
support for
Israel that's right that unwavering
support Darren comes in very tangible
form for those who don't know an
aircraft carrier strike group has an
aircraft carrier in several boats around
it capable of firing missiles and and
Performing other devastating functions
so there's that you've also got
additional fighter jets that have been
sent to the area the Secretary of
Defense in the US says that additional
Aid including Munitions have been sent
and will arrive in Israel Over The
Coming days that tells you they don't
expect this conflict to be over any day
soon so the US is is making this
commitment of deterrence um to deter
anyone else in the region from taking
advantage of this situation and
threatening Israel they are
investigating the possibility that Iran
might have been uh involved they so far
Anthony blinkin says they don't have
evidence of that but if that were the
case that would be one of those parties
that all of this is designed to
deter this is a massive terrorist attack
that is gunning down Israeli civilians
in their towns in their homes and as
we've seen so graphically literally
dragging people across the the border
with Gaza including a holocaust Survivor
and a wheelchair women and children so
you can imagine the impact this is
having throughout Israel and the world
should be revolted at what it's seen uh
we have immediately um engaged our
Israeli partners and uh and allies
President Biden was on the phone with
prime minister Netanyahu early yesterday
to assure him of our full support uh I
was on the phone with the Israeli
president the foreign minister the
entire government has been engaged
throughout the region and well beyond
and John so in terms of the Diplomatic
effort I mean Washington's been calling
for restraint but is it too early yet to
talk about any possible us role in
mediation well the US had been
attempting to mediate between uh Israel
and Saudi Arabia trying to develop a new
recognition uh of of mutual recognition
pact where those countries would
normalize their relations and now they
find they're scrambling in crisis mode
and they are doing diplomacy Lincoln has
been talking to his counterparts in the
region in the Middle East and in North
Africa and yes indeed part of that is an
effort to try to deescalate that
conflict another part of it is to try to
see what can be done to persuade Hamas
to release some of those captives that
is that it is holding some are thought
to be an American four American citizens
have died in that conflict among the
many others who have as well that's not
the only us interest but that gives the
US a direct stake there and they're they
want to be deeply involved in these
negotiations all right John hendren live
for us there in Washington DC John thank
you